when your skin is red when everything
stings if it's been really dry you've
been sick and you've blown your nose a
lot these are the products you can use
to get your skin buried the best chance
of recovering so you can go back to
using all the fun products hi it's
Michelle of lab muffin Beauty science
chemistry PhD cosmetic chemist and I try
a lot of products so I overdo it on my
skin sometimes mess up my Skin Barrier
and make it really irritated but that
also means I have a lot of experience
helping my skin recover and that's what
we're talking about today I also have my
friend Hannah English sharing her best
products she's a pharmaceutical
scientist and skincare content creator
she also has rosacea which is a really
confusing skin condition a lot of people
don't even know that they have it so
we'll be talking a bit about that too
let's start with active ingredients for
irritated skin I used to think that you
couldn't use any active ingredients if
your skin was really irritated because
so many of the really evidence-based
active ingredients like retinoids
exfoliants and vitamin C they're really
irritating it was actually you who made
me realize this which is why I got you
in this video what is your approach to
using actives on irritated skin I try to
think about it like does this ingredient
give back to my skin or does it take
from it what are some of your favorites
for calming down irritated skin and
supporting Your Skin Barrier panthenol
glycerin and hyaluronic acid so those
are hydrating panthenons a little bit
soothing as well niacinamide everyone's
fair but not too much like five percent
not 10 or 20 and then there's barrier
support so we have ceramides cholesterol
or you might see Fido's finger scene so
that's a lipid you find in the outer
layer of your skin and it helps to get
back to your skin those lipids that it's
maybe missing then we have soothing
ingredients so my faves are definitely
oat and also sentella so sikka madacast
aside and copper peptide so moving on to
specific products I don't know if I told
you this but your serum actually made me
realize how there were lots of actors
for irritated skin because I use your
serum and it was lovely on my skin and
then I looked at the ingredients list
and there was so much stuff in there so
side note I did not invite Hannah onto
this video because she's my friend and I
wanted to plug her serum we are going to
talk about other products but this was
like a revelation to me so the serum is
water-based and most of the time
water-based serums really sting when my
skin berries compromised and this did
not it just felt so lovely so my mind
was blown I feel like the oat is doing a
lot of the lifting there my skin was
stressed out while we were working on it
so it was good for me to test but what I
wanted was something that would feel
calming on contact I definitely did feel
like there was a gap that was not much
you could get especially in Australia
that would hydrate calm and support your
barrier that didn't feel like thick and
balmy I really love how lightweight it
is and how well it lays and like just
the fact that there's nothing like this
on the market I've been using this a few
times a week even when my skin isn't
that irritated because it just fits into
my routine so nicely what are your other
favorite products for when your Skin's
irritated I really like the La Roche
Superfast sheet masks you put it on your
face and it just feels calm it's
hydrated it's the best even after
treatments you know when your skin feels
really hot so I personally just don't
really enjoy sheet masks because I don't
like the feeling of them sliding down my
face so I love the sycoplast bun B5
which is getting reformulated to the B5
plus I picked up one up in Europe and so
far it seems to be pretty similar on my
skin maybe a little bit lighter but I
have heard different things from other
people a lot of people have told me that
they really like the sycoplast serum as
well but I haven't tried that enough to
really say it there are a lot of other
centella products that are formulated
for this sort of skin recovery phase as
well from Brands like bioderma and
there's quite a few in K Beauty I quite
like neodes copper peptide but the lipid
which is a sort of gel it's great
because sort of a one and done PM
routine Beauty Bay make this moisturizer
that's oat it's called First Class it's
kind of a bit richer so I would use it
in winter yeah I think oat is just
really underrated I used to make this
DIY oat mask back in the day that was
just ground up oatmeal mixed with water
and I would just slap it on my skin but
it has a lot of hydrating actors and I
mean ananthromise which are really
soothing if you fancy the Cosmetics 27
balm 27 which is sort of like a healing
oil balm really beautiful it has
essential oils but they're sort of
oatmeal calendula those calming ones not
the hectic lavender or anything like
that my nurse cream skin beautiful
doesn't have many ingredients I really
love that one too it's really
lightweight and less ingredients just
cuts down that chance of skin reactions
along the same lines with less
ingredients but a bit heavier there's
also Vaseline and Aquaphor which is
mostly just petroleum jelly and they're
water free so there's like a lot less
chance of stinging there's also CeraVe
healing ointment and the QV sting for
you ointment which is like the
Australian version of that and they both
have ceramides in them too I also really
like using face oils when I have that
compromised Skin Barrier because of the
lack of water it just doesn't tend to
sting as much but Paula's Choice
Advanced replenishing toner I feel like
reminds me of lineage cream skin only
it's packed with antioxidants as well so
it can almost be your am serum if you
want a bunch of antioxidants I quite
like my LED mask as well so I have one
that's red and near infrared I find when
I use it regularly my skin is just more
resilient and can tolerate more things I
get a little bit tired in the evening so
you just put it on and then you've done
skincare and it's one less layer on your
face I mentioned before that you have to
avoid retinoids exfoliants and vitamin C
but there are gentler versions of those
so what is your policy on using these
when your Skin's irritated it really
depends for me on how irritated my skin
is but I I do have some gentler versions
of my actives the Roche C10 is an
example that one has 10 vitamin C but
also their neurosensing peptide and a
bit of salicylic acid so I have
literally never had an issue with that
product and I have issues with vitamin C
and if I wanted to retinol it the
Kiehl's micro dose it's enough to have
an effect
but it's not enough to cause any issues
so that's also a perfect beginner
retinoid in general and it has ceramides
to replenish your skin as it works I
also really like using derivatives of
vitamin C and A where my Skin's
irritated because while there is less
evidence for them working they are a lot
gentler which I guess could be because
they're not working as well but it is
like a nice fall back option my favorite
less irritating derivatives for vitamin
C are ascorbal glucoside magnesium is
global phosphate and thga or atip which
are the same thing and for vitamin A I
like renactive retinoid for gentle
chemical exfoliation I like using
polyhydroxy acid although I do also
sometimes use a very small amount of
salicylic acid since it can be soothing
but you do have to be pretty careful
because a lot of the formulas are quite
harsh so one question I get asked a lot
is how long do you generally have to
wait for your barrier to fix itself
before you can go back to your usual
products I am getting pretty good at
repairing mine and recognizing the
science before I truly obliterate it so
a week or two recently I had a facial
where it was an enzyme exfoliant and it
was like a bit scrubby and I felt a bit
tingly around the mouth I thought it
would be fine it wasn't fine the next
few days it was tingly and so I just cut
the actives for about two weeks previous
times it's taken me three months that is
so long yeah I think it is just a lot
easier to not mess up your skin barrier
in the first place the longest my skin
has taken is probably a week or two but
it depends a lot on the type of
irritation so with perioral dermatitis
usually that is maybe a day or two if my
nose is peeling off after a cold then
that will usually be over a week now
with cleansers which ones do you like
for irritated skin I like to use
fragrance free cleansers and it's
because if your barrier is a little bit
compromised then things get in further
and so they wouldn't normally irritate
you but they can I like of an extremely
gentle cleanser I like biological that
is the one that's for oily skin but it's
a cream and I like a really soft
washcloth so like that really flammable
fluffy polyester I also like fragrance
free cleanses where my Skin's irritated
some of my favorites are from Geek and
gorgeous how to labo and Bondi Sands all
of those don't really strip skin and
like you said they have moisturizing
ingredients that give back to the skin I
also really like using bioderma micellar
water with soft reusable cotton rounds
the biodoma was specifically designed
and tested for sensitive skin and
reusable cotton rounds are just really
soft now we are Australians so of course
we have to talk about sun protection
what is your approach when your Skin's
irritated there are a couple of
sunscreens I know not to use because I
can feel a little bit spicy on the
cheeks if my skin is irritated but
generally I will look for one that is
formulated for sensitive skin I really
like those European Pharmacy brands
friends that catered to this type of
skin yeah I think there is this sort of
assumption that you have to use zinc
oxide if your Skin's irritated but
sometimes that's not the best option and
newer sunscreen filters can be really
non-irritating if you go into like a
French Pharmacy you'll see that all of
their sensitive skin sunscreens are
actually all chemical sunscreens they
have those newer filters some people
actually find zinc oxide more irritating
because it is drying and it's quite
irritating when you're rubbing it in
because it's so thick and sticky and
also just trying to get it off with
cleanser at the end on top of that
they're not always truly free from
chemical sunscreens I've talked about
this before but there are these SPF
boosters that are in a lot of mineral
sunscreens and they have almost
identical properties to a lot of
properly approved chemical sunscreens
I've actually talked to quite a few
people now who have told me that they
react to some mineral sunscreens and not
others and then they checked and they
saw that the ones that they do react to
have butyloft or salicylate late what
other tips and tricks do you have for
irritated skin I think a lot of people
don't know that your skin it exfoliates
itself right it's called discrimination
and it does that better when it is
adequately hydrated so I would always
try to hydrate my skin before I try to
exfoliate it if it's flaking or
something like that and you might find
that the flakes take care of themselves
that way I also really like doing
several layers of one toner putting
several layers of one product on is
better than putting four or five
different products right less
opportunity to upset your skin freak it
out I also find that with flaky skin if
I have to get rid of them before putting
on makeup then I will wet my skin and
use a peeling gel very very carefully
and just buff in tiny circles and that
seems to do the least damage but that is
like a really emergency sort of thing I
wouldn't recommend doing that regularly
when your skin is compromised because
the hydration technique is just so much
safer you also gave me some really good
tips for perioral dermatitis which is a
newer issue for me it it's a red rash
that comes up around your mouth and
nears the size of your nose and it's
been coming up more because of mask
wearing the extra humidity can lead to
an impaired barrier and imbalance
microbes and that can contribute to
perioral dermatitis so I've had to
change a few things when it flares up
like adding a cleanser in the morning
which I don't usually do when my skin is
happy then extra cleansing tends to mess
it up more and dehydrate my skin but
when that perioral dermatitis is flaring
then my Skin's already messed up so
cleansing actually takes it back towards
happy do you have any other tips if you
think it might be perioral dermatitis
never put steroids on it that's what Dr
caraism it's my beloved dermatologist
perioral dermatitis it's like imbalanced
microbiome but also it can happen from
steroid withdrawal because the steroids
put your immune system to sleep a little
bit your immune system was there sort of
keeping the microbiome in check speaking
of microbiome I found that I sometimes
get very superficial folliculitis on my
body when my skin gets irritated so like
after exercising and I'm sweaty and my
clothes have been rubbing in my armpits
and in like my crotchal region and it's
usually worse when I'm a bit run down
from stress and lack of sleep basically
this is when bacteria infect your hair
follicles and you get red bumps with pus
that look like shallow inflamed pimples
for these I like to use a benzyl
peroxide cleanser most of these are
meant for the face but dermatologists
have been recommending it for body
folliculitis too and it's been working
really well for me I use it right after
I exercise and also when I'm having a
flare and just also not marinating in
sweaty clothes helps a lot but if it's
really deep and painful and not going
away then definitely see a doctor
because you might need antibiotics or
something or it could be just not
folliculitis now rosacea I get asked
about this a lot and it's a bit of a
confusing condition that not a lot of
people talk about so what is rosacea
rosacea is a chronic inflammatory skin
condition it's basically my
dermatologist explained it to me as it's
the blood vessels that are inflamed not
the pores like you would have in acne
you'll see visible blood vessels so
those little red ones are called
telejectages redness flushing so you'll
see a symmetrical pattern of redness so
mine comes and goes so you might get
sort of a pimple like bump but it won't
be in the T-Zone it will be around the
cheeks and the nose in this pattern so
it's like w Zone not T-Zone it gets
confused a lot with acne and it tends to
show up from your late 20s onwards so
how did you first suspect that you had
rosacea I was at an event and Dr Dennis
was there and I said you know what I'm
always like flushing pink and red
through here sometimes through my cheeks
what's going on is that something I can
treat he's like well that's rosacea and
I was like
see ya I want to know why should you
actually look into managing rosacea the
thing about rosacea is that it
progresses so you'll start with just the
pink and the flushing and maybe some
visible blood vessels around the nose
you can get them in your cheeks too and
then you'll start to get lesions and you
can also have it get into your eyes and
then it can progress to thickened skin
and swelling in terms of treating
rosacea there are over-the-counter
options like azoleic acid you should
also see a dermatologist who is
experienced with treating rosacea and
they'll have other options available how
else do you manage rosacea Keeping On
Top of Your Skin Barrier and keeping
that in check in place really supporting
it is number one and avoiding triggers
so you'll notice when you start to flush
from certain things your sun is a big
one my skin hates the indoor heading
hates it alcohol some foods even spicy
food is a big one especially for like
pale people that only made individuals
some medicines even do it your skin care
or makeup could do it I feel like in the
skincare Community we talk so much about
acne but nowhere near as much about
rosacea so if any of this is sounding
familiar then you might want to read up
a bit on rosacea and consider getting it
checked out I'll put some more resources
in the caption and keep in mind that if
you have darker skin the redness will be
harder to see I hope you enjoyed this
nerdy chat if you did like the video to
train the YouTube algorithm to give you
more content like this also share any
tips you have and leave questions for
Hannah in the comments you can follow
Hannah here she's also written a great
book and you can see how much I'm
getting out of it from all of my tabs I
also have an ebook on skincare and I
hope this video helps your skin be less
grumpy at you